sans strap aller au jihad church road
selon le docteur alan bernstein la
science nous ne pas être menés par des
questions d'idéologie et le canada
devraient pas avoir peur d'être
considéré comme un éventuel voleur de
scientifiques américains
ils viennent possibilités réelles selon
lui pour le canada de renverser la
tendance des dernières années de ne plus
perdre de cerveau aux mains des
américains déclarent gouvernement
fédéral canadien avec le dépôt de son
budget cette semaine peut aider encore
davantage de canada a tiré parti d'une
situation politique scientifique
défavorables aux états unis le canada
lui-même se relèvent pourtant d'une
période trouble dans le domaine de la
recherche environnementale et
scientifique
ils sont difficiles ici pour nous de
faire la leçon aux américains si l'on
examine les gestes encore récent la
mémoire de beaucoup de canadiens de l'ex
gouvernement conservateur de stephen
harper il y a deux ans et demi à peine
par exemple 800 savants du monde entier
accusé le canada de retirer le droit de
parole à ces scientifiques
gouvernementaux
ces scientifiques de 32 pays dénonce le
fait que le travail de leurs collègues
canadiens était enrayée à leurs yeux par
des compressions budgétaires de
multiples contraintes sur leur liberté
de voyager de communiquer de collaborer
avec leurs collègues notamment des états
unis des centaines de scientifiques de
partout au pays pour manifester leur
désaccord avec les politiques du
gouvernement harper
sans la science pas de preuve pas de
vérité pas de démocratie des gens en
avril 2012
les canadiens avaient été témoins des
premières sorties publiques des
scientifiques canadiens qui affirmait
que leurs collègues du secteur public
faisait l'objet de muselage de la part
de leur employeur
on affirmait que plusieurs de ces
scientifiques qui sentent intimidés avec
tout simplement cessé de participer à
des conférences internationales pour
discuter des résultats de leurs
recherches
pour moi c'est très important la science
faire la recherche pas juste dans la
médecine mais aussi en écologie dans ce
parti et si vous couper les ailes les
fonds dans ceux ci comme directeur de
recherche en tant que parlementaire pour
prendre des décisions éclairées j tu
dois me baser sur des données fiables et
objectives et c'est ce que les
scientifiques qui travaillent au sein de
la du gouvernement du canada nous
fournissent aujourd'hui en 2017 des
scientifiques canadiens ont rebondi il
pointe maintenant du doigt le grand
américain et plusieurs boycott carrément
les états unis de 30 au niveau de la
tenue par exemple de réunion on déplace
maintenant au canada
point de départ depuis l'élection de
monsieur trump vient de grande
inquiétude parmi nos collègues
américains
certains ont été mis presque aubin parce
qu'une 1,7 et ouvert pour les
professeurs qu'on jugeait trop libéraux
par des huit ans conservateur et eugénie
guy lachapelle et politicologue à
l'université anglophone concordia à
montréal est aussi secrétaire de la
section canadienne des études
internationales
c'est un peu mieux que le faux le feu
aux poudres
les gens sont des pièces qu'on retourne
je m'écarte c'est ce qu'on va rechercher
identifier les professeurs qui qui ont
des idées ou qui font la promotion de de
ce type de certaines politiques par
exemple en environnement à des questions
de santé ou donc tout ça ça n'est un
climat un peu malsain d'autre part et
vous le mentionnez le décret de monsieur
tron face à l'humiliation affecté de
nombreux étudiants qui voulaient les
studios et au g10 infecter les
chercheurs aussi sont impliqués dans des
projets de recherche conjoints avec des
nos collègues américains
et sans compter tout ce qui est
collaboration avec des différents
organismes au niveau des universités
autres donc tous à sa main un climat de
méfiance d'inquiétude est un peu de deux
d'attentisme un peu par rapport à
monsieur tron parce qu'on on sait pas
trop ce qui va faire le lendemain et on
ne lui parle pas c'est que les
républicains ont pour beaucoup financer
la recherche aux états unis et ça et qui
est évidemment tous les chercheurs si si
on bénit la recherche brin sahbani
l'étudions noxa lors d un accident c'est
évidemment un peu partout dans un
reportage de radio canada international